hallo leute ich ist wieder eure mai war
bekannt zu einem neuen video
heute geht es um einen kühlschrank denn
ich bin jetzt auch tick tack tick tock
ist eine app die uns alle beeinflusst
und uns das gefühl gibt nicht genug zu
sein und deswegen werden wir heute
unseren kühlschrank pim wenn tik tok hat
eine welt von kühlschrank pim videos die
ich letztens entdeckt habe und jetzt
regiere ich erst mal zusammen mit meinem
freund timo drauf viel spaß
timo hat keine ahnung was ihn erwartet
du bist du wild bist du gespannt was sie
jetzt ihr anteil liegt bei bin absolut
es gibt ein video mit 7,5 millionen
aufrufen
oha lifehacker kühlschränke ist ich
zeige jetzt mal hier die kühlschrank die
gesicht aus ira sattler
[Musik]
kein wasser komplett andere
der mythos rausgeholt ja ich war also
nummer zwei hat 2,2 millionen aufrufe
und ist ein typisches kühlschrank mom
video wird und dass klein schreiben
ziemlich krank wenn wir so herzlich
sportlich essen wollen das ist
eigentlich nicht wenn man das zum
beispiel schon so oder so
paprikastreifen diese dosen in den
reggae hat dass man immer wieder
schmecken kann wenn man sich süßigkeiten
ein bisschen dieses komplette alle mit
zu kleinen schnitt oder alles
vorbereitet aber ich finds geil ist hat
alles so vom plastik entfernt ist ja und
also geordnet ist und nicht so zusammen
gewürfelt
doch das kommt erst wieder plastik
freiheit die anfänger passiv verpacken
konsequent durchgezogen aber mit mega
oder was hat genauso du hast dann alles
so rasch aus und konnten erst nach
meinem geschmack werde dann
geschmacklich groß ist ja erst wirklich
[Musik]
ja ich bin ich schon auch geil getränken
oder hat man nicht immer vollständig
supermacht vielleicht aber es stimmt
dass viele geile getränke als das ist
schon mal was wir auf jeden fall nicht
machen dass man es zu viele ungesunde
sachen kaufen dabei wenn süßigkeiten
brockhaus sind ist man sich wenn sie
nicht wissen sie können dem bau
[Musik]
das reh das gleiche auf gute alte
compact man wird ja wirklich voller gibt
es fällt uns negativ auf die alte ist
wirklich die juckt es gar nicht was
bekommen sie kauft alles alles schon
geschält und geschnitten in plastik sein
die heile wären so klar das kriegst und
plastik aber guck mal ich glaube sie hat
sogar die kiwis geschnittenen klasse ja
wie cool aus aber sie wenn er aus wie so
ein spiel
jaja beschreibt dicaprio anders aus bei
denen auch der schriftzug
das finde ich geil schlief halt einfach
zu einzelnen dosen kühlschrank ist schon
cool ja die man kann auch yoga
organisation
ja die von allemal ein paar
ich bin raus ich dem klub muss ich
leider sagen das wird unser ding jetzt
daraus also was die wichtigsten punkte
die wir uns merken plastik frei lassen
so gut es geht aus das hat eine so gute
verpackung aber so obschon also frisches
gemüse und so sagt klassiker seien ja
nicht viel passiert gerade alles schön
putzen viele getränke alkohol ganz
wichtig und dann würde ich sagen gehen
jetzt im supermarkt oder sollen wir dann
würde ich sagen damit man den
kühlschrank aus das ist jetzt ein
bisschen der walk of fame
let's go
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da wollen wir andere ist einfach erst
mal raus oder wie würde ich sagen dass
das ist wirklich schnell dazwischen ein
kleiner
klar braucht man zwei mal soße und ein
kampfspiel des kaufs durch das studium
gelungen leute das steht ihr nicht nur
locker locker die jahre ganz ganz tolle
empfehlung koreanischer kind die
salatbar jungs gemüsehof aus brandenburg
häufig über das sie hat sich schon
schimmel gebildet das war meine saft
kuba habe ich drei nicht getrunken
das ist chaim 300-mal marmelade dafür
war sieht auch wertet sie aus
[Musik]
es gibt so richtig dass es auch auf die
idee gekommen dieses system von den
gegentoren haben so jetzt aber mal über
timo du wolltest mich schon jetzt
endlich mal dich was bleibt ist ein
hebel blog ach ja da habe ich ihr dass
er das mit kultur entsteht weil sie zum
für sauerteig dass man die hilfe erst
mal
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt mit ihr putzt die menschliche
kette schlägt wieder zu
[Musik]
nutzen wir mal unsere jungs gleich
wieder
[Musik]
ein kühlschrank ist jetzt bevor wir
einkaufen gehen werden wir jetzt schon
mal dass ein lebensmittel einpacken und
schön einpacken was wir haben und sagten
wir einen blitzschlag ding braucht also
fangen wir an so die bürger anfangen
wir versuchen die weltherrschaft an uns
zu reißen planlos gut wie keine mayo
delikatesse
daneben muss nicht passieren war noch zu
den großen muss ist natürlich immer
augentropfen das ist teilweise einfach
standard der es gesetzt und er muss aber
auch so gehalten werden du kannst sie
wirklich
er war wirklich glücklich
die augentropfen wieder zurück slogan
nimm den sticker von den eiern und klebt
ihr das ist hier vielleicht gerade so
dieses ganze kreuzfahrt grünlich war
hier ist noch eines der schon vergammelt
hier kommt ihr abteilung und dann machen
wir auf dieser dieses shirt tomaten so
zum reingehalten cocktail den erdbeeren
so dass dieses projekt ganz große liebe
aufwachsen seine mutter aber
ich kann man das ja nicht so cool
sollte das ist ein prospekt oder am set
to make it also wieso willst du halt
auch mal was jetzt kommt nach hashtag
nach sport ich weiß es ist wirklich
nicht gesund aber
[Musik]
[Applaus]
er ist erstmal das eingekaufte working
poor heute wie man einkaufen wird heiß
der kühlschrank bekommt jetzt sei
schluss mit chery also keine werbung ist
alles hier hashtag nach sponsoren aber
ich hab' protein joghurt ohne laktose
gewinn ein produkt musste sein
die kassiererin hat sogar sehr gut drauf
reagiert er ab die müssen noch gewaschen
werden und absolute empfehlung summers
[Applaus]
[Musik]
heute eine sache habe ich in den tipps
gesehen die hat mich nicht losgelassen
so werden sie zum steak 48 prozent fett
das ist einfach ein fest in kauf dass
kaymer cool am stiel essen so leute
deine bereits zum großen kühlschrank
welcome to you live
[Musik]
das ist jetzt mein kühlschrank wie ihr
sehen gibt es eine reihe die auf
alkoholische getränke natürlich wenn wir
gäste empfangen sind wir gerne bereit zu
gewohnter zeit ein bisschen - aber naja
hier haben wir sammeln zum gähnen
mission holunder bionade cola red bull
proteine joghurt früchte zum snacken
habe ich auch mein traum rausnehmen und
die hinten haben wir noch mclaren oder
[Musik]
backwaren ja ja sag was in dosen muss
unsere quake gemüse auf schnitzel so ein
schritt nach mehr gemüse koste es hat
sich einfach gelohnt hat
klingt doch gemacht das ist doch klar
das kann jetzt auch tik tok finden es
mal wann folgt mir dort und wir sehen
uns das erste mal wieder
das ist ein rein bei